los croatas dirán adiós a las cunas y
darán la bienvenida al euro como moneda
oficial a partir del próximo primero de
enero yo seguro unirse al euro traerá
beneficios económicos tangibles para
croacia hará que sea más fácil y
atractivo invertir en su país reducirá
las barreras para las empresas y
eliminará el costo del cambio de moneda
también ayudará a estabilizar las tasas
de interés lo que facilitará y hará más
barato para las personas y las empresas
pedir dinero prestado tiene además un
impacto positivo en el crecimiento
gracias a la plena integración en el
mercado único de la unión europea el
euro sigue siendo una moneda atractiva
la segunda más importante del mundo por
encima del yen japonés pero debilitada
frente al dólar con el que estaba menos
de un céntimo de alcanzar una paridad
que no tenía desde julio de 2012
caída del euro puede crear más problemas
porque mucha gente que tiene ahorros en
euros se van a ir al dólar para esta
situación eso es justamente por lo que
estaba explicando que la suba de las
tasas de interés y el miedo que existe
en este momento
para los distintos
inversores de tener el dinero en europa
con todo este problema de guerra y
problema de
lo que es energía y pasarse a eeuu que
encontrar sus fallas sigue siendo más
seguro débil o no el euro es para los
croatas un símbolo de unión con el
bloque comunitario y una forma de seguir
los pasos de su vecina eslovenia también
ex república yugoslava que ya lo había
adoptado en 2007